(whooshing)
- [Announcer] This program
is a presentation of UCTV
for educational and
noncommercial use only.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome, everyone.
My name is Harry Scheiber.
I have the honor of being the chair
of the Jefferson Lectures Committee.
We nominate speakers and
help to organize visits
for this series which has
brought very distinguished people
over the years and is our
campus's leading annual lecture
in the social sciences.
These lectures were established in 1944
by a generous endowment
from Elizabeth Bonesteel
and her husband, Cutler Bonesteel,
a prominent San Francisco
couple who love this university
and wanted to provide
opportunities for the tradition,
the legacy of Thomas Jefferson
and to have distinguished
scholars and politicians
and journalists and other public figures
come to Berkeley to explore
the matter of the values
that are inherent in or that
challenge American democracy.
The details of our speaker's
career are in the program
and I don't want to take
more time than is needed,
so I will just say a few
words about his reputation
and his contributions.
Roger Daniels, more than any
other individual at the time,
took the history of Japanese
American internments
in World War II
and explored them from
a scholarly standpoint
and with a candor and a devotion
and an ardor, passion,
that has been undiminished
for the nearly 50 years since then.
He's done other writings on
immigration history generally
and on American history generally
and he's had a tremendous
influence as a mentor
of graduate students,
as a mentor to younger scholars,
and as a colleague of people
of his own generation,
I include myself,
who have written, in my case
co-written, in that field
and who still have to look to him
for authoritative judgments
on the issues of that
extraordinary episode, let
us hope it's extraordinary,
episode in American history.
It's a very special pleasure
to welcome our speaker, the 19 ...
I'm sorry, the 2010 ...
I'm an historian.
(audience laughing)
The 2010 Jefferson lecturer,
Professor Roger Daniels,
the Charles Phelps Taft Professor Emeritus
from the University of Cincinnati.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Harry.
What you're going to hear
is largely an oft told tale,
but it is a tale modified by being
in post 9-11 America.
What you see depends on where you stand.
First it is in order to provide a reminder
of what happened to Japanese Americans
after the United States
was attacked by Japan
in December 1941
and her allies Germany and Italy
declared war on the United States.
There were more than a million nationals
of the three main axis powers
living in the United States,
Hawaii and Alaska.
Nearly 700,000 Italians
and more than 300,000 Germans
had chosen not to be naturalized,
and about 90,000 foreign
born Japanese who,
like most other Asians, were
ineligible for naturalization
all became alien enemies.
Those who were 14 years of age and upward
were liable to internment.
Clearly the government had no prewar plans
for mass incarceration
nor any intention of rounding
up most alien enemies.
Federal authorities eventually interned
some 11,000 enemy aliens,
and the phrase Japanese American
internment is a misnomer.
Internment can only be done to aliens,
not to citizens.
Incarceration or some such
term is what has to be used
if you want to be accurate
with the mass of Japanese Americans.
Federal authorities eventually interned
about 11,000 enemy aliens,
about 1% of the total.
They took some 8,000
Japanese, 2,300 Germans,
and a few hundred Italians.
Although most proved no
threat to the United States,
their confinement conformed to the statute
and each was entitled to
a hearing without counsel
after imprisonment,
and as a result of those
hearings some were released.
In other words there was a
hint of due process in this.
Internment of 8,000 Japanese
men and a few women,
one in 11 of the foreign
born ethnic population,
included many community leaders
and most Buddhist priests,
language school teachers,
and was orderly and generally governed
by the rules set forth
in the Geneva Convention.
Initially federal authorities
carefully distinguished
between aliens and citizens,
but as far as most
Americans were concerned
the 275,000 Americans
who looked like the enemy
were the enemy,
something reiterated by journalists,
radio commentators and politicians.
Some two-thirds of the 275,000
were birth right citizens.
The majority of Japanese Americans,
some 150,000 lived in
the territory of Hawaii
and were so vital to its functioning
as the focal point of the Pacific War
that a real military necessity required
that almost all of them,
regardless of citizenship,
be left at liberty.
Their wartime story will
not otherwise concern us
this afternoon, although
it needs to be better known
and for those of you who are interested,
Harry Scheiber and Jane Scheiber
are telling part of that
story in a forthcoming work.
Our chief concern is the 125,000 Japanese
in the 48 states and Alaska.
90,000 of them lived in California
with most of the rest in
coastal Washington and Oregon.
They and the very few in Alaska
and a small part of Arizona
were eventually subjected
to mass incarceration.
The few thousand who
had lived in or fled to
the rest of the United States
lived throughout the rest of the war
in a kind of nervous liberty.
But the West Coast Japanese Americans,
men, women, children, and infants,
were exiled from their
homes in the spring of 1942
in what we have learned
to call ethnic cleansing,
were temporarily warehoused
in unsanitary fairgrounds,
race tracks, and livestock
pavilions close to their homes
for months before being shipped off
to 10 ramshackle purpose
built concentration camps
in late summer or fall.
These were in desolate
places where few people
have ever lived before or since.
This exodus has been
authoritatively described
as caused by racism, war hysteria,
and a failure of political leadership.
Factors, I must say, that
are still active and viral
in our political life.
But history is made by men and women
and we need to understand
who caused this disaster
of democracy and why.
The perpetrator in chief was
Franklin Delano Roosevelt.
On February 11th, Secretary
of War Henry L. Stimson,
who the night before,
in other words the night
of February 10, 1942,
had written in his diary the following.
"The racial characteristics
"of the second generation Japanese
"are such that we cannot
understand or trust
"even the citizen Japanese.
"This latter is the fact,
but I am afraid it will make
"a tremendous hole in
our constitutional system
"to apply it."
He telephoned Roosevelt to make that hole
and asked for authority to
remove the Japanese Americans
from the West Coast.
He reported to his key subordinate,
Assistant Secretary of War John J. McCloy,
that the president had
given him carte blanche
in dealing with the
Japanese on the West Coast,
adding only, "Be as
reasonable as you can."
Eight days later, February 19, 1942,
the real date of infamy
for constitutional liberty,
the president signed
Executive Order number 9066,
which had been written
in the War Department
to give the Army absolute power
over the West Coast Japanese Americans,
although neither they nor any other group
is named in the order.
Why did Roosevelt sign it?
There is no definitive
answer to that question.
The president never once
discussed his decision publicly,
or as far as we know in private.
It seems to me that his perception
of political realities
and political advantage
at a time when the war
was going very badly
for the United States,
and his greatest domestic
concern was national unity,
was that such an action was expedient.
A great clamor raised about the
dangers of Japanese American
sabotage by journalists,
radio commentators,
politicians and professional patriots
had made it seem to be
the expedient thing to do
and Roosevelt's reaction responded to it.
No major act of his wartime presidency
received greater approval from the public.
Soon thereafter he was willing
to ameliorate his decision
in certain ways.
When encouraged by educators,
including the president
of this university,
Robert Gordon Sproul,
as well as by some of his own aides,
Roosevelt ordered in the spring of 1942
that incarcerated students
might be released to attend
colleges and universities
away from the West Coast,
and in 1943, as part of
restoring the right of Nisei
to enlist in the Army,
he said that, "Americanism
is a matter of the mind
"and of the heart.
"Americanism is not and never was
"a matter of race and ancestry."
Many young Nisei in
camp did in fact enlist.
Others asked, "If that is the case,
"why are we in concentration camps?"
A year later the president
restored another right,
the right to be drafted.
Most of those called up for the draft
while in concentration camps obeyed,
but a significant minority resisted,
although they could neither flee nor hide.
There is no time today
to go into the conditions
of camp life.
Except for the camp of Tule
Lake which became a place
where the government sent troublemakers,
the treatment was generally humane.
The American concentration
camps were not death camps,
but on several occasions
incarcerated Japanese American
protesters confronted
armed American soldiers,
and as would happen later at Kent State
and at some black colleges,
some protesters were shot and killed.
In one instance in an isolated portion
of the Utah concentration
camp known as Topaz,
a soldier in a guard tower shot
and killed an aged prisoner
and went unpunished,
although the available forensic evidence
justifies an indictment for murder.
Government lawyers had
feared that the courts might
interfere with incarcerating
civilians by military means
without a declaration of martial law,
but alas, their fears were unwarranted.
The courts in wartime almost
always give the government
great latitude in questions
that claim to affect
national security,
and the Roosevelt court, he
had put each man in his seat,
was no exception.
Four Nisei in their 20s who
did not know one another
and had little institutional
or community support
and much opposition from Japanese
American community leaders
nonviolently resisted
the government's efforts
to incarcerate them
and instituted lawsuits
that reached the Supreme Court,
which in the Japanese American cases
rendered three terrible
decisions in June 1943
and December 1944,
effectively ratifying
Roosevelt's decisions
and the actions of
Congress to implement them
as a constitutional
exercise of the war power.
In the first case, Hirabayashi,
the court said that, "Imposing a curfew
"only on persons of Japanese ancestry,
"even if they were citizens
of the United States,
"was permissible."
In the second case,
Korematsu, it said that,
"A citizen of Japanese ancestry
"who failed to report for
certain exile and incarceration
"when ordered to do so by a general
"could be punished."
In the third case, Endo,
ruled that a loyal
citizen could not be held
but only reference the
war relocation authority
rather than the president who created it
or the Congress who
appropriated money for it.
The Endo decision did have the effect
of forcing the government to
cancel the longstanding orders
that prevented most
citizen Japanese Americans
from returning to their West Coast homes,
even after they had been
released from camps.
Apparently two justices had
tipped off the White House
and/or the Army as to what Endo would hold
and the government
announced the cancellation
of those orders, keeping
people off the West Coast,
the day before the decision
was announced by the court.
It was very much what Justice
Brandeis might have called
a dirty business.
The court's December 1944 decisions
did speed up the closing of the camps
which were in progress.
Many of those who have
written about the wartime
Japanese Americans comment appropriately
on their resilience,
often comparing them to bamboo,
but such celebrations all
too often ignore the fact
that many were so traumatized
by their experience
and fearful of what life
outside camp might hold for them
that they literally had to be evicted
so the camps could be shut down.
In postwar Los Angeles and
elsewhere on the West Coast,
where most returning Japanese began to
reestablish themselves economically
without significant government help,
there were more Japanese,
mostly elderly aliens,
on relief than there
had been in the depths
of the Great Depression.
The government did little
to ease their passage.
The WRA, the War Relocation Authority,
furnished camp leavers
with train or bus tickets
and $25 a head.
In July 1946, President Harry S. Truman
had a ceremony staged on the
ellipse behind the White House
for elements of the Nisei
442nd regimental combat team.
He gave the combat team,
a much decorated unit,
its seventh distinguished unit citation
and remarked that, and
I quote the president,
"You fought not only the enemy,
"but you fought prejudice
and you have won."
Truman in his 1948 civil
rights message noted that
100,000 Japanese Americans
were evacuated from their homes
in the Pacific states solely
because of their racial origin
and, I quote, "Suffered
property and business losses
"as a result of this forced evacuation
"through no fault of their own."
At his urging, Congress
enacted the Japanese American
Claims Act, appropriating
$38 million to settle claims
that eventually totaled $131 million.
Congress refused in
1948 to make a judgment
about the 1942 decision.
As the Senate committee
on the judiciary put it,
"The question of whether the evacuation
"of the Japanese people from
the West Coast was justified
"is now moot," end of quotation.
The Justice Department
in a 17 year process
litigated and adjudicated
claims aggressively.
One case file that I examined
of a Japanese American
who had lost his farm in
Kent on Seattle's east side
because he could not meet
his mortgage payments
while in camp.
The file showed that he
had received only half
of the reduced settlement
agreement he had signed.
When he complained, the Justice Department
explained it to him.
Washington was a community property state
and since his Caucasian
wife did not have to
accompany him to camp,
he, really they, could be
compensated only for his half
of the loss, not for her half of the loss.
In September 1950, after the
beginning of the undeclared
Korean War, Congress
passed over Truman's veto
the Internal Security Act of 1950,
an extreme example of
legislative hysteria.
A part of it known as the
Emergency Detention Act of 1950
introduced and supported
by democratic liberals
including Hubert H. Humphrey
and Herbert H. Lehman
was explicitly modeled
on the procedure used
to incarcerate Japanese Americans.
Because, as its sponsors
repeatedly pointed out,
the procedure had been
approved by the Supreme Court.
Must be all right then.
The purpose of the statute is described
in section 101 paragraph 14.
I'm gonna read some legal language
and you got to listen carefully
because this is unbelievable.
"The detention of persons
"who there is reasonable
grounds to believe
"will commit," future tense,
"or conspire with others
to commit espionage
"is in a time of internal
security emergency
"essential to the common defense
"and the safety of the
security of the United States,
"the people and the constitution
of the United States
"do declare that the
president," this is section 103,
"acting through the Attorney General
"is hereby authorized to
apprehend and by order detain
"each person as to whom there is,"
and again this wonderful language,
"reasonable grounds to believe
will probably engage in
"or probably will conspire to engage in
"acts of espionage or sabotage."
It did not say what would happen
if they just dreamed of them.
This is the method of Executive Order 9066
with the Attorney General substituted
for the Secretary of War,
and ideological enemies
substituted for ethnic ones.
It remained unused as a kind
of sleeper law on the books
for some 20 years.
The only part of the
law that required action
was a provision providing
that standby facilities
be prepared and making the
tie to Japanese American
incarceration a little clearer,
the facility at Tule Lake was designated
as one of the standby detention camps.
After massive numbers
of Chinese volunteers
entered the Korean conflict in late 1950,
many Chinese Americans
feared that they might become
the target of government reprisals,
and there was heightened activity
by the Immigration and
Naturalization Service
against Chinese Americans
who were perceived
to be Communists,
including a confession
program which offered amnesty
to persons who had entered
the United States illegally
as so called paper sons
if they would inform on
relatives, real and fictive,
who were radicals.
At the same time the Justice
and State Departments
tried to prevent Chinese nationals
who had received scientific
or technical training
in American college and universities
from returning to China,
although they would let
them return to Taiwan.
Further emphasizing the
ending of ethnic exclusion
was dropping the ethnic
bars to naturalization,
begun with the repeal of the
Chinese Exclusion Acts in 1943
and continued piecemeal until 1952
when the otherwise reactionary
McCarran-Walter Act
made naturalization colorblind
while increasing ideological
barriers to immigration
and even prohibiting visits,
including academic visits,
to the United States by persons
believed to be Communists.
The long overdue admission
of Hawaii in 1959
changed the political
dynamics for Japanese
and other Asian Americans.
The House of Representatives
had voted to admit Hawaii
in 1947, 1950, and 1953,
but southern democrats in the Senate
had blocked it each time.
Ernest Gruening, the new dealer
who oversaw the territories
and island possessions
remembered that after
several Japanese Americans
had testified during statehood
hearings in Hawaii in 1937,
Mississippi's John E. Rankin
turned to him and said,
"My god, if we give them folks statehood
"we're likely to have
a senator named Moto."
In fact from its first
post statehood election,
Hawaii has sent a steady progression
of Asian Americans to Congress
beginning with Hiram
Leong Fong in the Senate
and Daniel Ken Inouye in the House.
It is difficult to overstate
the positive effect
that this representation has
had on the changing roles
of Japanese and Asian
Americans in American life.
Now that we have reached what
is roughly the halfway point
in our story, it seems appropriate to ask
where, in what the Library of Congress
delights in calling the American memory
were the wartime experiences
of 120,000 Japanese Americans
nearly a quarter of a century
after all of the camps
which held them had been closed down.
One cannot say that their
experience was secret or unknown.
It had been described in
daily wartime newspapers
and there had been books and articles
by scholars and journalists,
but there was simply no
place in the victory culture
which dominated the
postwar quarter century
for what could be called
an American war crime.
Particularly one that
claimed 120,000 victims.
Many of those victims themselves
wanted to hear no more about it
and many of the younger Nisei and Sansei
literally knew nothing about it,
including some who had
been born in the camps.
College students learn precious little
about what happened to Japanese
Americans in that time.
The year I began my graduate
study at UCLA, 1957,
not one of the several historians
teaching survey courses
in American history even
mentioned it in lectures,
and the most extensive
standard textbook treatment
in a book whose lead author was the iconic
Columbia historian Richard Hofstadter,
who gave this lecture in 1966,
allotted it just one long
sentence which I'm gonna read.
"Since almost no one doubted
the necessity for the war,
"there was much less
intolerance than there had been
"in white World War II,
"although large numbers
of Japanese Americans
"were put into internment
camps under circumstances
"that many Americans were later
to judge unfair or worse."
End of quotation.
Many college texts of those
years said nothing at all
about the Japanese
American wartime or ideal,
and I am not aware of any mention of it
in a secondary textbook before 1965.
For most of the rest of the afternoon
I'm gonna try and trace and explain
how the World War II mass incarceration,
so little noted in that
first quarter century
following the war, was restored
to the American memory.
Two distinct narratives of
this restoration have emerged.
One celebrates the eventual
vindication of a betrayed people
and is the kind of stories
that audiences like to hear,
and I'll tell it,
while the other makes the incarceration
an increasingly
influential reference point
for those concerned with the
expansion of the American
security state and the
corresponding shrinkage
of individual rights.
Thus the tale becomes both
triumphal and cautionary.
The focus of the story also changes.
Before 1970, Japanese Americans
were largely portrayed
as the objects of history.
After that time they
regularly appear as actors
affecting their own destinies.
By the beginning of the 1970s,
a growing sense of Asian
American community consciousness
was developing.
Nowhere stronger than in San Francisco,
where the engineer historian Him Mark Lai
and the community activist Edison Uno
and others created the
first college courses
in Asian American history
at San Francisco State College.
Courses long shunned by more
prestigious universities.
Uno, one of the first to propose
what became known as redress,
was instrumental in a campaign
aided by the Hawaiian
Congressional Delegation
to repeal the Emergency
Detention Act of 1950,
the act whose terms I read earlier,
and Assistant Attorney General
told the Senate judiciary
committee that the unfounded fears
of many Americans, that the
act might be used to apprehend
and detain citizens who
hold unpopular beliefs,
and that the repeal of this legislation
will allay such fears.
This benefit outweighs
any potential advantage
which the act may provide.
The repeal, which was passed
by lopsided majorities
in both houses in September 1971
and signed by the President Nixon,
was called the Non-Detention Act,
contained the following sentence.
"No citizen shall be imprisoned
or otherwise detained
"by the United States
"except pursuant to an act of Congress."
It was made nugatory by
the 2001 Patriot Act.
President Gerald R. Ford,
in a move that surprised contemporaries,
chose the 34th anniversary of
Roosevelt's executive order
to repeal it with a
bicentennial proclamation
which observed that an
honest reckoning of history
had to acknowledge our national mistakes.
"We now know," the president said,
"what we should have known then.
"Not only was that evacuation wrong,"
first time an American
president had said that,
"but Japanese American were
and are loyal Americans."
Ford's proclamation, little
notice in the National Press,
had a paradoxical effect
within the Japanese American community.
Conservative community leaders
who were resisting efforts
by mostly younger activists
who were calling for a formal apology
and some kind of monetary compensation
could now argue that Ford's
action was such an apology
and that attempts to get
monetary compensation
were unrealistic.
The activists of course drew
particular encouragement
from the action by a generally
conservative president.
The Redress Movement
was eventually embraced
by most Japanese Americans.
The stunning, unprecedented,
and highly improbable result,
Harry Katano called it
the impossible dream,
that the activists eventually
gained from Congress
and a president went on until 1988
and was not fully consummated
until February 1999.
The struggle within the
Japanese American community
was acute and complex,
and I'm not gonna go into all the details.
Initially only a minority
favored a campaign for redress.
The yet as unpersuaded majority
was not so much opposed
on principle, although
such opposition did exist,
but it was rather a matter of misbelief
as to the possibility of a good result.
After two failed attempts
the activists succeeded
in getting the endorsement
of the ethnic group's major organization,
the Japanese American
Citizens League, JCL,
at its 1978 convention.
Its chief goals were a
formal apology from Congress
and individual payments
to victims of $25,000,
thereby setting an upper
limit on what individuals
could even hope to receive.
Only then did the JCL committee
appointed to direct the Redress Campaign
meet with the Japanese
American members of Congress
to plan strategy.
It received a rude awakening.
The elected officials, with
Senator Inouye taking the lead,
said that no bill calling for compensation
could possibly pass,
but promised to support a bill
calling for the appointment
of a presidential
commission to investigate
what happened in 1942
and recommend any remedies
that it found appropriate.
This upset an awful lot of people.
The committee was forced to
accept the commission's approach
and the bill sponsored by Inouye,
with more than a majority
of the Senate as cosponsors,
easily passed Congress in the closing days
of the Carter administration,
under whose aegis the
commission was appointed.
The misnamed committee
on the wartime relocation
and interment of civilians
was a blue ribbon group
whose most effective members
were former Supreme Court
Justice Arthur J. Goldberg
and Philadelphia Judge William Marutani,
the only Nisei on the panel
who had been incarcerated
briefly in camp at Tule Lake
before being released to go to college.
It took testimony from
more than 750 witnesses
during 20 days of hearings in the Capitol
and cities across the country,
particularly on the West Coast.
Although one erudite but
insensitive staff attorney
described the hearings as,
"Irrelevant freak shows,"
they were an important rite of passage,
as hundreds of former camp inmates
narrating their captivity
after four decades of silence,
often punctured by tears,
shouts, and curses,
and otherwise behaving in
ways the Japanese Americans
rarely behaved in public.
A few years later they
surprised not only themselves
and their children and
their grandchildren.
A few years later a
Nisei woman speaking to
a Nisei Week audience
at the 50th anniversary
of her wartime acceptance at
a small Missouri Bible college
out of camp said that, "I
never said anything to anybody
"before speaking at a commission hearing.
"That loosened my tongue
"and I have been talking about it,
"what it was like in camp, ever since."
The CWRIC published its unanimous report
titled Personal Justice
Denied in February 1983.
It was a rude and branch condemnation
of what the government had
done to Japanese Americans
which concluded that, I'm
gonna read a long paragraph,
"Executive Order 9066 was not justified
"by military necessity,
"and the decisions that followed from it,
"detention, ending detention,
and ending exclusion
"were not driven by analysis
of military conditions.
"A grave injustice was
done to American citizens
"and resident aliens of Japanese ancestry,
"who without individual review
"or any probative evidence against them
"were excluded, removed, and
detained by the United States
"during World War II.
"The report was issued
without recommendations,
"which were delayed until June."
That was in February.
One commissioner, sitting Republican
Californian Congressman Daniel Lee Lungren
dissented from the recommendation
of a monetary award to individuals.
The other eight commissioners
agreed that each survivor
should receive a one time
compensatory payment of $20,000.
Other recommendations
were for a formal apology
from the Congress,
a presidential pardon for
all who were convicted
of violating edicts of the
Western Defense Command,
and that the Justice
Department review all federal
convictions of ethnic
Japanese during the war,
congressional instructions to all agencies
to be liberal in restoring
any rights or benefits
Japanese American might have lost
because or stemming from
their wartime mistreatment,
and finally that Congress
fund an educational foundation
to educate Americans about
what their government
had inflicted on Japanese
Americans during the war.
The bill that enacted the
commission's recommendations,
the Civil Liberties Act of 1988,
was given the number HR442,
the designation of the Nisei unit
which fought so well in Italy and France.
Meanwhile in November 1983,
five months after the
commission's recommendations,
a federal district judge in San Francisco
voided Fred Korematsu's
original conviction,
which had been upheld by the Supreme Court
in the most potent of the three wartime
Japanese American decisions.
This highly unusual,
perhaps unique situation
had come about because Peter Irons,
a political scientist and attorney,
had in the course of researching a book
about the Justice Department,
found evidence of blatant misconduct,
deliberate suppression of evidence,
in the preparation of
the government's brief
presented to the court in 1943 and 1944.
Irons and a group of
largely Sansei attorneys
all working pro bono were able to reopen
not only Korematsu's
case in San Francisco,
but Hirabayashi's case in Seattle
and a second curfew case involving
Minoru Yasui in Portland.
Only Korematsu's case
need concern us here,
although all the cases are important.
The attorneys applied successfully
for a writ of coram nobis,
the Latin means "the error before us,"
which had been used by
the way by Alger Hiss
in his unsuccessful
attempt to get his 1950
perjury conviction overturned.
After considerable delay
the Justice Department
moved to vacate the conviction.
In other words they were willing to say,
"Okay, vacate the conviction."
But refused to admit previous
government misconduct.
The district judge Marilyn
Hall Patel, a Carter appointee,
ruled the government's
motion out of order,
accepted Korematsu's petition coram nobis,
voided the original indictment,
and reversed Korematsu's
original conviction.
In her opinion, she warned that,
this was in 1983,
"Korematsu stands as a constant caution
"that in times of war or
declared military necessity
"our institutions must be vigilant,
"that the government must not be used
"to protect government
activities from close scrutiny
"and accountability."
The successful attorneys
were delighted by the victory
but were disappointed that the
government failed to appeal,
as they had hoped that the
case might be again heard
by the Supreme Court and reversed there.
In addition, their victory
was one more argument
for the Redress Bill in Congress.
Reagan's Justice Department,
opposing the bill, told a
congressional committee,
"It may be the commission is correct
"in concluding that the assumptions
"on which the exclusion and
detention programs were based
"were erroneous,
"but some of its conclusions are wrong.
"These matters are best left to historical
"and scholarly analysis rather
than debated by Congress."
The legislative process
was painfully slow.
A divided Congress, Republican
control of the Senate,
Democratic control of the House,
the hostility of the administration
and the constant budget
crises of the 1980s
meant that final passage
came more than five years
after the commission
issued its recommendations.
HR442 initially passed the Senate
by a comfortable 69 to 27 margin,
but similar House approval
by a vote of 243 to 141
was close enough to suggest
that a presidential veto
would be upheld,
and all the signs were
that Reagan would veto it.
But on the day that the
conference committee report
adjusting minor differences
between the House
and the Senate versions
was to be voted on,
the president sent a letter
to the Democratic Speaker of the House
endorsing the bill and urging its passage,
and I quote him, "To end a sad
chapter in American history
"in a way that reaffirms
America's commitment
"to the preservation of
liberty and justice for all."
At the bill's signing ceremony
the president read from a
December 1945 newspaper clipping
describing General Joseph
W. Stilwell's award
of a posthumous
Distinguished Service Cross
to the sister of Staff
Sergeant Kazuo Masuda
of the 442nd at her farm home
in Orange County, California.
Ignoring what General Stilwell had said,
the president still
reading from the clipping,
"Described how the motion picture actress
"Louise Allbritton, a Texas girl,
"told how a Texas battalion had been saved
"by the 442nd.
"Other show business
personalities paid tributes.
"Robert Young, Will Rogers Jr.,
"and one young actor," and
this is still quoting Reagan,
"one young actor said, 'Blood
that has soaked into the sands
"'of the beach is all of one color.
"'America stands unique in the world.
"'The only country not founded on race
"'but on a way, an ideal.'"
The name of that young actor,
I hope I pronounce this
right, was Ronald Reagan.
Unlike many of Reagan's anecdotes,
this one was largely true.
(audience laughs)
The young actor of course was 34 year old
Air Force Captain Reagan,
completing his three
years of military service
for which he never left home
because it was all in Hollywood.
Stilwell was doing what he was doing
in response to orders from Truman
after he had been alerted
by Eleanor Roosevelt
about the abuse returning
Japanese Americans were receiving
after returning to the West Coast.
Reagan's lines were written by military
public relations writers.
Despite the low comedy of the ceremony,
something important had been
done and something unique.
A victorious nation acknowledged
that it had done wrong
and paid a significant price for it.
Eventually some 82,000
persons received payments
totalling $1.6 billion,
and in an echo effect in the
days after Reagan's signing
the Canadian government
concluded negotiations
with a Japanese Canadian
organization for similar payments,
$21,000 to a much
smaller number of victims
of its parallel wartime policies.
While human rights advocates had hoped
that the principles and
meaningful monetary redress
for wartime actions against
the nation's own citizens
would be adopted elsewhere,
it has had no tangible effect
outside of North America.
An important intangible change
was that the wartime
exile and incarceration,
all but forgotten in the postwar decades,
was firmly implanted
in the American memory.
This was demonstrated
with striking clarity
in the aftermath of what we
have learned to call 9-11.
In the days following the destruction
of the World Trade Center
and its more than 3,000 dead,
and throughout the nine years
since that horrific event,
countless persons have
raised the haunting specter
of Arab or Middle Eastern
or now more often Muslims
becoming the 21st century's equivalent
of Japanese Americans.
Historical analogies are
always tricky propositions,
particularly when one is dealing
with a contemporary event.
Current history is after all
a contradiction in terms.
Nevertheless there are
striking similarities
as well as differences
between the events of 1941-45
and those of our current decade.
In both periods, race prejudices
augmented by religious
prejudice in our time
and war hysteria were
abundantly prevalent,
but at the highest levels
of recent government
there were repeated warnings
not to make assumptions
about guilt based on race,
ethnicity, or religion,
and there was an almost total restriction
of prohibitive actions,
of punitive actions,
to non-citizens.
But when it came to treatment of prisoners
we must remember that
while the World War II
Afrika Korps veterans brought to America
later described their
places of confinement
as goldene kafig, a golden cage.
No such praise will
come from the survivors
of Guantanamo or its
populist version Abu Gharib.
While in the aftermath of
Roosevelt's 1942 order,
there was almost no public criticism
of the extreme measures taken
against Japanese Americans,
so many public figures
and others made reference
to the Japanese American
experience after 9-11
that it seems obvious that
it increased awareness
of what had happened in 1942
was a factor in the
heightened sensibilities
about violations of civil rights in 2001,
and no one should imagine
that what has happened
in the last nine years
is on the same scale
as what happened in 1942.
Some critics have insisted
that even to mention
both eras in the same breath
is inappropriate and worse.
Those optimists assure us
that a mass incarceration
of American citizens
in concentration camps will not recur
and point to the relative mildness
of the governmental reaction after 9-11
as evidence of that.
But reflection on our past suggests
we ought not to be so sanguine.
We must remember that it
was not just the disaster
at Pearl Harbor,
but the subsequent sequence
of Japanese triumphs
that triggered Executive Order 9066
74 days after Pearl Harbor.
Shouldn't we ask if terrorist
attacks on American soil
had continued after September 11th,
would the current government reaction
have been so moderate?
And were there to be a
recurrence of such a tax,
would there not be those in
our security establishment
who would argue that the
moderation after 9-11
was a contributing factor
in the renewed assaults?
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Man] In February 1941 I was a teenager
and I can remember very clearly
that we were told that there
were Japanese submarines
off the California coast,
God knows how many,
and that there have been
signals back and forth
from the land to the subs,
from the subs to the land,
and of course this was,
we talked about the national hysteria,
this was sort of the basis of it.
I was wondering what can you tell us
that the West Coast military command,
what did they tell Washington
about the situation
at that time?
Were they part of this canard
about the Japanese subs?
Did they tell Washington
we needed to do this?
Did they tell them we should not do it?
What can you tell us?
- Well, first of all
there were two submarines,
one of which popped up off Santa Barbara
and fired several shots
at some oil tankers ...
At some oil tanks on the
hillside and missed them.
The commander of that sub, by
the way unlike most commanders
of Japanese submarines, survived the war
and was interrogated by American officials
and he said that he was terrified,
that he was sure that
the entire American Navy
was gonna pounce on him immediately,
but actually there were no warships at sea
within hundreds of miles of where he was.
There's no evidence whatsoever of signals.
Washington was told in the report
from the Western Defense Command
of Lieutenant General John L. DeWitt,
again who I haven't
mentioned in this lecture,
that there were all kinds of signals,
radio signals and others,
and that has been proved
to be a total canard.
That was a lie.
There was hysteria.
The Army quickly understood
that the Japanese,
that the Great Los Angeles Air Raid
was started when one gun
near Santa Monica fired
at a weather balloon
thinking that it was a Japanese plane,
and then antiaircraft guns all over.
It was the middle of the night.
Antiaircraft guns fired hundreds of rounds
and insurance companies
knew because there was
great damage to automobiles
parked on the streets
of Los Angeles when some
of the shrapnel comes down
because you send one of those
things up and it explodes
and comes down to Earth.
There was not one single
documented instance
of espionage or sabotage,
and to anticipate a question
about the governor of California
who was at that time ...
I think he really wants me
to talk about Earl Warren
who was the governor of
California at that time.
It was bad enough but wasn't
as bad as his attorney general
Earl Warren, who at a meeting
of law enforcement officials
said accurately, "There
hasn't been one single case
"of espionage and sabotage.
"That's what makes it so dangerous.
"There's a conspiracy to lull us to sleep
"and our time will come,
we don't know when."
So that's why it was necessary.
In other words the same kind of
paranoia we saw in the
Emergency Detention Act
and we've seen in the Patriot Act
and all sorts of other activities.
- [Woman] Hi, I was just wondering
whether Eleanor Roosevelt
made any comments about
this in her papers?
Did she argue with FDR?
Was there --
- No evidence of that.
She accepted it.
She thought it was unfortunate,
and everybody was very well
traumatized in Washington.
It was made worse when
a Supreme Court justice
came back from Hawaii
with the false reports
that they had been sabotaged there
and that's what caused everything wrong.
She did go fairly early on
to visit one of the concentration camps,
and wrote a few letters for individuals
who were recommended to her
to help them get out of camps,
but there's no evidence.
We don't know.
We don't know what she
may have said privately
to her husband,
but she never claimed
to have been against it,
and in some of the ...
In the introduction to a book
called Beauty Beyond Barbed Wire
published shortly after the war,
she described it as an
unfortunate unavoidable necessity.
That's not a quotation.
That's a description of what she said.
There's a widely held myth
in the Japanese American community
that Eleanor Roosevelt was their champion,
and it's just not true.
But she did go to
one of the camps.
She did say things like, "I'm
sorry that you're all here."
I think she was very sympathetic
and she was very, very good
at projecting empathy,
but that's where it ended.
- I think that this
concludes our formal session.
I know there are always
more questions at the end
but we do have to end these events.
I can't say enough, Roger,
how much we appreciate our
and Judith Daniels, your wife,
an awesome historian, coming to Berkeley
and sharing this day with us.
I should also add that Professor Daniels
has been very generous with his time
and meeting with students and faculty
during his visit to our campus,
so it's in a sense the model
of Jefferson lecture visit
for us on the faculty who organize this.
I want to remind you
that we have a reception
planned in the back and you
are all very welcome to join.
I think that Professor
Daniels will be here
for at least a few
minutes to join with you.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
(lighthearted music)